trek c'est assez inquiétant tout ça
alors justement on est en campagne
électorale alors quelle est la position
des partis là sur cet enjeu on va
commencer à z par le parti libéral qui
importe un programme assez détaillé
justement pour le contrôle des armes à
feu d'abord ils veulent interdire
complètement les armes d'assaut
militaire même les ar 15 donc ça c'est
vraiment la pièce centrale de ce qu'il
propose on veut aussi faire un rachat
des armes des particuliers ça existe
déjà dans certains pays comme en
australie
donc on voudrait racheter justement les
armes d'assaut on veut aussi poussé les
propriétaires d'armes à feu à mieux les
sécuriser mieux les entreposer pour
éviter que ça se retrouve un jour dans
la nature
et puis on veut surtout donner beaucoup
plus de pouvoirs aux municipalités pour
qu'elle gère dans le fond l'accès à ces
armes à feu pour leurs citoyens
c'est d'ailleurs un peu le genre de
mesures que propose également les
néo-démocrates dans plus de pouvoir on
décentralise vers les municipalités
on veut aussi investir dans la
prévention pour les jeunes pour ne pas
qu'il soit avec en contact en tout cas
avec les fameux gagne 2 rue qu'ils aient
accès justement à ces armes à feu et
puis on veut aussi travailler beaucoup
sur la contrebande de ces fameuses armes
à feu sur le fameux marché noir et
d'heure c'est ce que propose également
aussi le parti conservateur c'est assez
central dans ce qu'il propose parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas punir ceux qui
achètent de façon légale leurs armes
donc encore une fois on veut vraiment
ciblé la contrebande d'armes à feu on
veut aussi interdire à vie toute arme à
feu pour ceux qui ont eu des
condamnations pour des crimes violents
on veut également suspendre
temporairement l accès les armes à feu
pour les personnes qui ont des problèmes
mentaux et on veut donner plus d'argent
et de pouvoir aux policiers d'ailleurs
le parti vert s'en inspire un petit peu
en donnant justement plus de moyens aux
contrôles au service des frontières
rachat également de certaines armes
comme le font les libéraux dans leur
programme et enfin un mot sur le parti
populaire très libertariens vous ne
serez pas surpris
là on veut transformer le système de
permis d'armes à feu en acquisition avis
donc pour protéger les droits des
propriétaires d'armes à feu et on veut
également offrir ce qu'on appelle ont
fait de légaliser en fait la possession
d'armes à feu pour qu'on puisse les
utiliser de façon légale donc c'est
vraiment un peu dans tous les sens